disco delivers affordable science-backed
skin care treatments to your home the
disco starter set helps guys fight oily
skin and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get 30 off at letsdisco.com
pacman the link is down below
well everybody they uh they passed
something they they did pass something
and we're going to talk about what that
something is after months of
negotiations as some have called them
um the house on friday passed a much
smaller
1.2 trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill
not every democrat voted for it and some
republicans voted for it those
republicans are now
being told they're going to be removed
by other republicans but we're going to
get to that
it does finally give joe biden
something that can be called a win
it's a much smaller win than i hoped for
for the good of the country it's a much
smaller win than democrats most of them
hoped for
from the standpoint of politics but it
did pass the house 228 to 206 and this
is
mostly a bill
with what republicans would call
real infrastructure spending now we
don't really go by calling things what
republicans call them because if we did
we'd be very stupid um but
what what others refer to to this type
of spending as is hard infrastructure
big investments in roads bridges
waterways um and other things that we're
going to talk about some that i'm
pleased to see to be perfectly frank uh
13 republicans voted in favor of this
bill
six democrats voted against this bill
the 13 republicans voting in favor
mostly the folks we aren't surprised to
hear would cross party lines to vote in
favor the democrats voting against
supposed progressives as they are often
described and you know we can talk later
about whether we're surprised that they
voted against it or not nancy pelosi was
negotiating biden was helping try to get
it done um and finally on friday they
got the vote now the house goes to a
recess then they're going to take up the
social spending bill also known by some
as build back better
many saying that's dead others saying no
sir it might pass what some have said
they want before they will consider the
buildback better bill is a score from
the cbo
as to the total cost and economic impact
of the social spending bill slash
buildback better bill so this is not
that this is the infrastructure bill now
again remember
this is
if you already were
ashamed at the size of this package
okay
because it's 1.2 trillion instead of two
three trillion
it's number one 1.2 trillion over eight
years uh and only 550 billion of the 1.2
trillion is new spending the rest is to
fund existing programs so what we're
talking about here
is a package
that is 69 billion dollars per year in
new spending
for an economy the size of the united
states economy
this is not a massive package at all
we're not talking about an amount of
spending that should be this difficult
to get done now what is in the bill
specifically well let's look at it
110 billion for roads bridges
infrastructure fix-ups across the
country all right 73 billion for
electric grid and power structures even
that some republicans were saying that's
not really what we should be doing in
infrastructure spending uh hint it is um
66 billion for rail services we have
summers of the most pathetic rail in the
rich developed world
65 billion for broadband
we have pathetic broadband access in the
u.s 55 billion for water or water as
some say
um that's again we
there's still part
can they even drink water in michigan
out of the tap yet in flint michigan i
don't think they can
21 billion for environmental remediation
47 billion for flooding coastal and
climate resiliency very much needed as
uh we deal with sea level rise 39
billion to modernize transit
25 billion for airports our airports
many of them are pathetic 17 billion for
port infrastructure remember they're mad
we don't have more room in ports to get
the chinese tchotchkes in for christmas
but they also don't want to spend on
ports well this bill would do some of
that 11 billion in transportation safety
programs 7.5 billion for electric
vehicles and charging i would honestly
like to see that much higher
i would also have loved to have seen
spending on
retrofitting for
retrofitting homes to be
completely electric but when you go
electric you can't have that inefficient
electric baseboard heating we want to go
with the super efficient heat pumps and
mini split systems and then solar
you can go house by house
listen to a very interesting podcast
about this recently you put solar panels
on the roof
you get all of the oil and uh gas heat
out you get the inefficient um uh window
acs out right i mean you go to fully
electric but
efficient electric would like to see
more on that okay 2.5 billion in zero
emission buses 2.5 billion in low
emission buses and 2.5 billion for
ferries now you might notice nothing for
sinks and showers which donald trump was
obsessed with nothing for toilets
it seems we're not really having to
flush toilets 10 to 15 times under joe
biden as donald trump predicted but a
lot of good things being done now if you
add that all up it's 544 billion
i called it roughly 550.
what's the rest you might be saying it's
a 1.2 trillion dollar package david you
only read 550 worth of spending well
it's programs already in existence
and again
the fact that there's this much arguing
over a bill that
as it's left mostly funds existing
programs it is globally humiliating so
politically biden needed something this
is
something it's not
great
without it it's a political disaster for
joe biden and with it there's still more
stuff to get done but it's at least
something to justify another three
months in the oval office right it keeps
you treading water you've not drowned
but you're not safe on shore either it
keeps you treading water is sort of the
way that i would describe it so that's
what's in the bill that's what passed so
far
we now have to talk about
instantly
the civil war republicans again coming
for their own saying those 13
republicans who voted for this uh we
gotta remove those people so okay we
already talked about mostly democrats
but not all democrats combined with a
few republicans in the house
came together
they passed a much smaller than
initially proposed bipartisan
infrastructure bill good
some republican house members broke with
republican party leadership like kevin
mccarthy who were saying don't help
democrats pass the bill they weren't
making an argument about the necessity
of the bill they weren't making an
argument about anything other than don't
help democrats pass the bill
trump republicans are absolutely furious
with those few republicans that voted
for the
infrastructure bill in the house
and they are now vowing to remove
the republicans from the house quite
frankly this is great
democrats are not very competent we have
a competence problem and certainly i can
speak to the united states if you've
been watching the kyle rittenhouse trial
with us you very quickly see there's
just a lot of incompetence in general in
the general public
and that means a lot of democrats aren't
competent and that applies to the
democratic party last week's election
results looked terrible for democrats
heading into 2022.
the biggest gift
that republicans
can hand
to democrats
is
that they fight amongst themselves
13 house republicans crossed party lines
and they voted in favor of the
bipartisan infrastructure bill six
democrats also crossed party lines and
voted against the bill and republicans
are going nuts over those 13 republicans
florida republican congressman anthony
sabatini tweeted quote every republican
who voted for the infrastructure bill
must be eliminated from the party
colorado uh representative lauren bobert
maybe one of the worst people
currently involved in american politics
quote rhinos meaning republicans in name
only just passed this wasteful 1.2
trillion dollar infrastructure bill but
pelosi did not have the votes in her
party to pass this garbage
time to name names and hold these fake
republicans accountable
north carolina congressman madison
cawthorn tweeting quote vote for this
infrastructure bill and i will primary
the hell out of you
josh barnett who calls himself an
america first
candidate for the arizona house
tweeted 13 republicans just voted to
turn america into a communist country
they should be pushed back on so hard
until 2022 that their lives are
miserable till we have them removed by
the way building a bridge is not
communist fixing roads isn't communist
saying hey
if we want people to buy electric cars
how about chargers for the electric cars
that's not communist and in fact all of
those things support private industry
and reality matt gates also jumping on
the bogus socialism fear-mongering
tweeting i can't believe republicans
just gave the democrats their socialism
bill not only is the bill not communism
the bill is also not socialism but lots
of his followers believe it
there has been this idea historically in
the republican party
they love calling themselves the big
tent party we welcome all sorts of views
we welcome uh this type of conservative
and that type of you know okay as long
as you vote for republicans and not for
democrats is voting with democrats sort
of the same as voting for democrats in
the minds of these trump republicans i
say let them fight encourage it actually
it can only be good for the left i would
rather
democrats be more competent and and win
elections more regularly by being
competent
i'm very worried that that's not the
case going into 2022. and so
i will take any help that the left can
get
and republicans fighting amongst
themselves is a good thing in terms of
helping the left now at the same time
the stupidity of infrastructure bills
are communist and socialist
that's something else and i wonder if
you went to these folks and you said do
you do you understand do you know about
the military
taxpayer-funded socialism
with mandatory vaccines to boot
but that's different of course these are
folks who at the end of the day they
want king emperor trump
and reality doesn't really make a
difference to them they don't even know
the things they want to destroy but they
know they want to destroy a lot of them
in government remember i i was reminded
of just such a classic political moment
when
former texas governor rick perry ran for
the republican presidential nomination
he had a bunch of departments he wanted
to remove couldn't remember exactly what
they were but he definitely wants to
remove him remember this insane moment
it's three agencies of government when i
get there that are gone
commerce education and the uh uh what's
the third one there let's see
epa epa there you go no again let's talk
let's talk
seriously
[Applause]
is epa the one you were talking about no
sir you can't name the third one
the third agency of government i would i
would do away with the education
the
commerce
commerce
and let's see
i can't the third one i can't sorry
oops so anyway they definitely want to
destroy
a lot of the stuff the government is
doing
and sometimes they don't even remember
all of it but now
building roads and bridges is is yet
another thing i guess they don't want
the government to be involved in so
my message is absolutely get these
republicans out challenge them primary
them do all of it
because the left needs help guys
after last week
it's it's looking very ugly now some of
you wrote to me and said david you're
you're exaggerating it's not looking
that ugly in 2022.
yes it is and even if we're not sure
it's looking that ugly do we really want
to take any chances my view is no
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter
deepakman
one of our sponsors is disco there are
so many different types of bogus skin
care products for men out there what you
really want to go with is just something
affordable effective and created by
dermatologists that's why we have disco
which delivers the science-backed
over-the-counter skin treatments that
dermatologists recommend to their
patients every day the disco starter set
is a simple way to take care of your
skin in three quick steps the face
cleanser stick fights oily skin
the exfoliating face scrub prevents
razor burn and the face moisturizer
keeps your skin hydrated disco can also
help with ingrown hairs dry skin acne
and other things you just need 60
seconds a day i've been using it for a
while now i'm seeing a noticeable
difference maybe you can even tell check
out disco try out the products for
yourself you will like the results and
you'll get thirty percent off when you
go to
letsdisco.com pacman or just enter the
code pacman the link is down below our
program the david pakman show does
really depend on the support of our
podcast listeners of our youtube viewers
of folks who listen on the radio or
watch on tv or on free speech tv we have
something called the membership program
you can sign up on my website
joinpacman.com
we do a whole bunch of extra content for
our paid members to show our
appreciation including another show
every single day so you've got the
broadcast show the podcast
and then we do another show called the
bonus show for our paid subscribers i
would love it if you signed up you can
sign up at joinpacman.com also you get
commercial free audio feeds and video
feeds of the show so if you want to
watch the entire thing with no
commercials you can do it as a member if
you want to listen to the entire thing
with no commercials you can do it as a
member we also have a discount code that
code is better21 and you can use it if
you would like
all right big news at least for now and
by tomorrow this may be different the
joe biden vaccine so-called mandate as
it is known
is going to be
frozen frozen uh thanks to the decision
of a panel of republican appointed
judges now what we call the vaccine
mandate
which is why i said so-called
is the requirement through osha
that companies with more than 100
employees either
have their employees get vaccinated and
prove that they are vaccinated or you
just test them weekly for covid so it's
not much of a mandate but it's a
protocol requirement call it whatever
you want remember that fox news's
protocol or requirement or whatever is
stricter than what joe biden has put in
place via osha at fox you have to prove
your vaccination status or test daily
and wear masks in certain situations all
right well per the washington post a
federal appeals court has suspended has
frozen the biden administration's new
vaccine requirement for private
companies the federal appeals court in
new orleans one of the most conservative
appeals courts in the country
is giving the biden administration until
later today to respond to a lawsuit
filed by republican-led states and
businesses the decision was issued by a
panel of three judges all appointed by
republican presidents this is the u.s
circuit court of
u.s court of appeals for the fifth
circuit
the judges wrote that there was quote
cause to belief
there are grave statutory and
constitutional issues with the mandate
they have stayed the mandate while it is
assessed further
what started
all of this
was a lawsuit filed late last week just
before the weekend by some republicans
including louisiana attorney general
jeff landry now it's really important
this is a temporary freeze on biden's
quote mandate it is not a ruling on the
merits of the policy they want more time
to look at it it's important to recall
that vaccination requirements at the
state level
at local levels
by schools by private companies they
have almost
completely held up in court so far
the biden requirement is different in
two ways number one it's broader and
number two it's coming from the federal
government so it is different that
doesn't mean it's not going to
ultimately stand it is also not actually
a mandate since you can test out
doesn't apply to employees who work
remotely or outdoors
doesn't apply to people who physically
work
where other people
don't work or shop
and as we talked about last week these
requirements
do work to get people vaccinated very
much so you can argue that it should be
against the law uh you can argue that
it's immoral
but it works and it works really really
well when we look at companies ranging
from
united airlines to the new york police
department to all sorts of companies
including ones where people were
claiming i will i'm not going to do it
i'm not going to do it it works very
well now going back to the politics this
ruling was signed by judges one judge
was a reagan appointee just judge edith
jones and then kyle earn kyle duncan and
kurt engelhardt both were appointed by
donald trump this was the new
orleans-based fifth circuit
court
considered one of the most conservative
appeals courts in the country it is
likely that other circuit courts even
given the same case would find
differently it is likely that such a
decision would probably not be upheld by
the supreme court if it ever got to that
point although
we have a little bit of a wacky supreme
court right now and you never know white
house chief of staff ron klain was asked
what do you think is ultimately going to
happen he says he's confident it will be
upheld of course he would say that but
let's listen to his reasoning i want to
ask you before i let you go about the
court ruling yesterday on the vaccine uh
on on the vaccine protocols that osha is
putting out
sort of the soft mandate i don't want to
call it a hard mandate because of the
testing option
uh
there's a freeze what does that mean for
the federal government's efforts i mean
do you stop preparing for january 4th in
the moment how does this work
well i think what it means for
the time being is that uh the the
effectiveness of that vaccine
requirement is is frozen i think it will
certainly be well litigated though well
before january 3rd so i'm not sure
really has much practical effect in the
short run
look these vaccine requirements have
been litigated up and down the courts
all over the country state requirements
for example one in maine
and every single court before this one
ruled that they were valid the supreme
court has turned back several times
already various efforts to enjoin
other vaccine requirements i'm quite
confident that when this finally gets
fully adjudicated not just a temporary
order uh the the validity of this
requirement will be upheld it's common
sense chuck if osha can tell people to
wear a hot hard hat on the job to be be
careful on chemicals it can put put in
place these simple measures to keep our
workers safe so of course you would say
that with the trump travel ban with
trump with all sorts of different things
trump did
no matter what courts were doing you
always say i'm confident it will be
upheld until there's actually a decision
otherwise but i do think ron claim is
correct on this that being said
there's a reasonable question
was this requirement through osha the
best way to deal with anti-vaccine
republicans or has actually served to
energize them further
i'm very interested in how the french
have done it i have a family
uncle cousins in france and they came to
me and they said sir because that's how
my cousins talk to me they are very
respectful of me they said um you know
here in france we have a big
anti-vaccine problem
we have the distrust of government
people who are anti-vacs like in the us
and we have the distrust of big pharma
people here in france like in the us and
you've got a lot of people here who
believe homeopathy will treat or cure or
prevent covid
you've got all of it and if they had
done a mandate in france it would have
been absolute pandemonium france took a
different approach where they said you
don't have to get a vaccine but if you
want to travel you want to go to a movie
theater you want to go to a restaurant
you want to go to the great cafes where
you get the salmon tartare and these
great dishes which i love there um
if you want to do all of that stuff
you just are going to either need to be
presenting a negative test from i don't
remember if it's 24 how many hours every
single time
or you get vaccinated
and the brilliance of it was it diffused
the narrative of a mandate but it was
like this is something really annoying
and so you had some people from all
walks of the anti-vaccine world
saying
i'm not i'm not for the vaccine
but i just want to do something there's
a specific thing i want to do it's not
about just being able to go to work so
i'm going to go and i'm going to go and
get vaccinated i don't want to have to
test all the time i want every time i
want to go to a restaurant or whatever
the case may be so i'm wondering aloud
is that an approach that could have been
maybe more effective but then you have
the question of
is that something biden could really
even do or does it have to be done at
the state or local level our system is
different than that uh
which which is the case in in france so
be curious to hear from you about that
a massive cartoonish dramatic episode
has surfaced over the weekend
because nfl football player aaron
rodgers who's the quarterback for the
green bay packers
is in the middle of a covid
i don't even know what to call it it's
not really a scandal it's sort of like
an episode of stupidity for lack of a
better term it's a wild story and quite
frankly it's a reminder to us that there
are dumb people in this country in all
professions in all walks of life with
all educational backgrounds and of all
economic circumstances so here's the
story
37 year old aaron rodgers tested
positive for covet
didn't play yesterday against the kansas
city chiefs great
he previously claimed to have been
immunized now whatever he meant by
immunized
we now have learned he's not been
vaccinated against covet 19. he says
he's allergic to the vaccines he's
taking ivermectin he says awoke mob has
come after him they're trying to cancel
him per nbc all of this different stuff
now before we get into
the new material on this
here is aaron rodgers
in august when he was asked
have you been vaccinated and he says
i've been immunized which
okay we'll talk about in a second take a
look at this any conversation
are you
and what's your stance on vaccinations
yeah i've been immunized um
you know there's a lot of a lot of
conversation around it around the league
and a lot of guys who
have made statements and i made
statements
owners who made statements right um
you know there's guys on the team that
haven't been vaccinated
uh i think it's a personal decision i'm
not going to judge those guys
um those guys have been vaccinated
they've contracted kovid
so
okay so that was august 26th and he says
i've been immunized
we of course are now learning among
certain people immunized means very
different things there are people who
say well i haven't been vaccinated but i
was sick with covid so now i'm immune
there are other people you go further
down the rabbit holes right who say i
took ivermectin
and received antibodies and azithromycin
and so now i'm immune
okay so he maybe was just lying or he
believed he had been immunized through
some other means it's not really clear
so then we get to this weekend he's
positive for kovit he's not playing
yesterday etc he appears on the pat
mcafee show sports analyst podcaster
pro wrestler color commentator former
football punter okay pat mcafee
um
and rogers says well you know i've been
getting medical advice from joe rogan's
podcast
and from uh joe rogan
on the phone personally
and pay attention in this clip if you're
watching pat mcafee who's on the left
can barely contain his laughter it's
actually it's quite something here let's
take a look and
i consulted with
a now good friend of mine joe rogan
after he got covered and i've been doing
a lot of the stuff that he recommended
in his podcasts
and you know on the phone to me
and
i'm going to have the best immunity
possible now based on the 2.5 million
person study from israel
that the people who get covered and
recover
have the most robust immunity
and i'm thankful for people like joe
stepping up and using their voice i'm
thankful for my medical squad
um and i'm cool for people like joe
stepping up and using their voice i'm
thankful for my medical squad
um okay just repeated there for some
reason i don't know why and i'm thankful
for all the love and support i've gotten
but i've been taking
monoclonal antibodies ivermectin zinc
vitamin c and dhcq
and
i feel pretty incredible okay
it's it's fine actually to get advice
from friends about their experiences
right like if i
tested positive for kovid
um
i would also go and talk to friends and
say what what was the progression of
your symptoms and
when
that's it's not inherently bad
but coming up with the view
that you got
from joe rogan which is counter
to 99.99 of medical science
lying or
who knows what you meant when you said
i've been immunized
and then you say this you you don't look
particularly smart i think is the point
i'm trying to make and rogers has
described himself as a critical thinker
he said at another point during this
interview which i encourage you to check
out um he said that he put together a
500 page uh
set of research of some kind which he
gave to the nfl
and pat mcafee asked him how did the nfl
respond and rogers said well they acted
like i was a quack
um and he at one point actually mentions
that you heard him say there i'm gonna
have the best immunity and later in the
interview he explained you know look at
the israeli study which says recovering
from covid gives you better immunity
than getting the vaccine okay
uh let's actually um let's let's look oh
no yeah i'm not gonna play a clip for
that but you can find that clip so a lot
of people have been mentioning that what
about that israeli study does it
actually say
that you're better protected if you
recover rather than being vaccinated
rogers is repeating it others are
repeating it it's not actually what the
study says what the israeli study says
is first of all
if you recovered from covid on average
you're more protected against delta
than
uh from only being vaccinated and that
appears to be true
in particular if you've been infected
more recently by a strain more similar
to delta it appears that you are more
protected against delta if you recover
from the virus rather than only get
vaccinated um in the short term at least
and that kind of makes sense right the
vaccines were developed to tackle the
original or live variant at some point
maybe soon we're going to have a vaccine
that's actually tailored to delta or
newer variants but
the vaccines were developed based on the
2020 live original variant so if you're
infected more recently and the vast
majority of the infections have been
more recent than
from when the vaccine was developed it's
logical that your current protection
against the current strain might be
stronger however if you look at the
israeli study it also says covet
recovery plus vaccine
gives you the best protection the best
protection overall
so wouldn't you want that given the
option between recovery
or recovery plus vaccine which gives you
better protection i would want recovery
plus vaccine and my preference would
actually be not to get the virus at all
also that study is from august it was
published in august and it's based on
data slightly before that the virus
continues to change and there's a real
question as to how
recent infection would compare to
vaccination by next fall for example
so as usual a little bit of knowledge
can be a very dangerous thing all right
now there's a ton of stuff we could look
at here
um here's another
short clip where roger says no one wants
to admit ivermectin works because
there's no money in ivermectin which
is not true but he almost stumbles upon
something with a grain of truth if
you're a healthy person
who has a strong immune system keep
building your immune system
and
and do what you got to do do what's best
for your body
but that opinion
you know doesn't work because
we you know
we you know we've given away billions of
dollars these pharmaceutical companies
now for these for these vaccines and
it's not going to stop mark's coming out
with a pill uh you know pfizer's coming
out with a pill that's gonna help
you know it's it's it's basically the
expensive versions of ivermectin why do
people hate ivermectin not just because
you know trump championed it
because cheap generic
can't make any money off it
but it's been used a billion times in
india go look at that research what's
going on over there yeah
so we've heard that the none of these
are new talking points these are all
talking points we're familiar with
the thing he gets close to is
the reason that cheap generic stuff like
ivermectin is tried against covid is
you've got a new disease
you've got people dying
you don't yet have vaccines you don't
yet really have treatments so what do
you do
you see
does anything i have that's cheap work
okay so the right analysis is and we've
talked about it before with doctors
you're sitting around you go
what do we do okay let's try
hydroxychloroquine
let's try ivermectin it's cheap let's
try azithromycin let's try zinc let's do
vitamin d
the fact that it's cheap generic stuff
is why it gets tried absent unknown
immunization or treatment that's been
studied uh further
but this stuff has been tested
and i wish iver mektin was shown to work
in randomized controlled placebo trials
i wish it was it would be fantastic
but it hasn't so he almost stumbles upon
something that's like sort of true but
he just then goes completely off the
rail so this is really sad because these
are the same opinions as lots of people
on facebook have maybe your crazy uncle
or whatever but this is someone that is
considered a role model by society
not saying he should be but he is
and unfortunately a lot of people listen
to what he has to say so send me your
thoughts we'll have more on this aaron
rodgers fiasco on our instagram which
you can find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so at the start of today's show we went
over the passage in the house of
representatives of a much smaller 1.2
trillion dollar infrastructure bill and
this may be good for joe biden joe biden
needs something good joe biden needs to
get something done the negotiation on
this bill has dragged on too long in
particular for how relatively little you
actually got in the bill and
increasingly there is this urgency for
an accomplishment for joe biden because
if we just look at the numbers this is
just an empirical reality of joe biden's
approval rating has hit another
presidency low the lowest point of joe
biden's entire presidency now i tend not
to look at any one poll i look at an
average of polls
tracks an average of biden approval
polls and if you're watching today
rather than just listening you will see
on your screen right now that there's
been a steady decline for joe biden's
approval this started around late july
and i mentioned it to you when it
started
and it has continued to decline and this
has pulled joe biden down from around 53
approval
below 50 into the high 40s
mid 40s and now down to the low 40s 42.6
approval that's the lowest of joe
biden's presidency now anecdotally if
you want to pick one poll
there are some polls that have joe biden
in the 30s and you could say disaster
even bigger disaster there are some
polls that still have joe biden near 50.
on average he is now in the low 40s now
there is not one explanation for this
and you need to understand a little bit
of history in general to even start to
interpret these results and there's this
kind of systemic historical reality of
presidential approval which is that it
typically starts sort of high
and then typically as the president does
things that different people don't like
people change from saying i approve to i
don't approve and it's really difficult
to get someone who stops approving back
into the i approve uh category or column
which is why presidential approval tends
to decline over time and that's what we
see over the majority of presidencies
now for joe biden the trajectory has
basically been approval started
declining when the delta wave of covid
started to look really really bad that's
middle to late july and we saw the
approval start to decline as i said at
the time
ultimately the buck stops with joe biden
the truth is the delta wave was more out
of control in the united states than it
had to be because of red state governors
um anti-massacres
and anti-vaxxers
really
they were to blame for the exacerbation
of the delta wave not joe biden but joe
biden's the president and the buck stops
with him and it's logical that if things
are looking out of control his approval
would decline now before biden could
recover from that initial decline he was
then hit with another problem which was
the withdrawal from afghanistan the
withdrawal was correct the right move
uh the right uh i supported it
completely it was time to go it would
have been just as chaotic if donald
trump had done it if not more
but it was biden who did it and the buck
stops with him and the media narrative
particularly from the right but also
from some centrist corporate media of
chaos really hurt joe biden further
as people started to forget about
afghanistan remember how long has it
been since anyone mentioned it it
started to become what is joe biden
doing chaos at the border was a
right-wing narrative when is biden going
to have a big accomplishment became a
broader and accurate narrative that's a
real question when is joe biden going to
have his next major accomplishment he
needed something a big piece of
legislation the negotiation around the
infrastructure bill and the build back
better bill it dragged on and on the
attention became the relative power that
joe manchin and kirsten cinema had
rather than joe biden it was taking
oxygen and the approval continues to
decline
we now have some shortages and supply
chain issues which we had under trump
gas prices and inflation have climbed as
the pandemic recovery continues and joe
biden is president
so fairly or unfairly he gets blamed
that's the game so now he finds himself
at the bottom i mean so far the bottom
it could continue down he is currently
at the bottom of his presidency's
approval now you combine this with last
week's losses and barely wins for
democrats
2022 can't be said to be looking good
right now for those who say it's not
looking that bad okay there's no
indicator that 2022 looks good
first the
first midterm
for a party that wins the white house
is typically not good
uh in addition biden is at his approval
low of his presidency plus democrats had
some bad signals during last week's
elections now that being said joe biden
is still doing better today than donald
trump was at 292 days into his
presidency biden is doing worse than
most presidents were right now obama was
more popular at this point in his
presidency george w bush thanks to 911
was way more popular
clinton was more popular than biden at
this point in his presidency george h.w
bush was more popular reagan was more
popular but at this point in trump's
presidency trump's approval had already
collapsed to 37 percent and biden's
between 42 and 43 so at least that's
something to look at trump was still
worse that all being said
we may simply be in a sort of new era of
politics
in which presidential approval is mostly
low because it's expected that if the
person in the white house is from the
other party
you say you don't approve regardless of
what the president has actually done
it's a sad reality we may be facing uh
biden does need more wins that i can
assure you and we'll see where the
approval is a couple weeks from now
as you of course know
much of the american republican party
has now
had as a default view of election
integrity
if we won
there was integrity but if we lost there
was fraud and it was rigged this is the
premise of the big lie as it's called
which emanated from donald trump's loss
to joe biden back in november of 2020
now more than a year ago last week
before the election in which republican
glenn young defeated democrat terry
mcauliffe you already had some
republicans claiming fraud here's an
example i played for you last week this
was virginia republican state senator
amanda chasing the democrats are already
committing voter fraud and she knows how
look
um i'm all about fighting for the truth
too and and sometimes unfortunately we
can't always rely
on the media i wanted to go there i
wanted to feel it i wanted to see a
picture's worth a thousand words i know
how democrats are are cheating and that
information has been given to the yonkan
campaign well they're going to try to do
it in fairfax county absolutely you know
i'm already getting reports today
that people are going to vote and they
have never done a mail-in ballot ever
and yet when they went to cast their
ballot they were told no we've already
mailed you a mail-in ballot and so we're
already looking into that that's that's
why we told everybody in virginia vote
early so that couldn't happen the
earlier you voted they couldn't do it
now they're starting to do it there were
other examples but you get the idea but
then last week glenn younkin won the
election all talk of fraud ceased none
of them are talking about fraud anymore
remember that there's this invisible
sort of like a flow chart did the
republican win yes
then there was no fraud
that's essentially the way it works well
it turns out there was attempted fraud
listen to this nbc news is reporting
that glenn younkin's own 17 year old son
twice tried to vote last tuesday on
election day even though you can't vote
when you're 17 years old in the u.s you
have to be 18 to vote now he was not
successful in his attempt to vote
news outlets are not naming him because
he's a minor and he hasn't been charged
with a crime but by saying glenn
younkin's 17 year old son we know who it
is
he showed up to vote and election
workers figured out he's not eligible to
vote he's not registered to vote he 17
and he was not allowed to vote the
fairfax county office of elections is
investigating the incident the office of
elections said in a statement this
morning the general registrar was made
aware of concerns that a 17 year old
male attempted on two occasions to vote
on election day the young man presented
id but was ineligible to be registered
due to his age and was not permitted to
vote the man was given a registration
form and encouraged to register in the
future when he's 18 is what that means
now the funniest plot twist would be
that he was trying to register to vote
for terry mcauliffe not his own dad we
have no reason to think that that was
the case in all seriousness what's sort
of funny but also not really funny is
that it doesn't actually seem like he
committed a crime because of how the law
is written even though there are people
in other states who are imprisoned for
accidentally voting when not eligible
fairfax county registrar scott knopsick
said it's not clear any crime was really
committed because the virginia criminal
code makes it clear if you use
fraudulent information to vote that's
against the law
but simply trying to vote and being
determined ineligible
that's not clearly addressed in the
virginia code and ultimately the quote
is the man did not vote he made no false
statements he did not disrupt voting it
appears as though no actual crime was
committed now that being said
remember in texas crystal mason
who was previously sentenced to five
years in prison
for making a mistake and vote that was
not counted despite being ineligible
that's texas texas upheld that sentence
we have a very different situation here
in virginia but the people most loudly
talking about the fraud
seemed to disproportionately be the ones
attempting to commit it so just a little
minor follow-up story there from the
glen younkin election in virginia we're
gonna take a quick break and we have
much more coming up right after this
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show all right a couple of
other quick stories for you that i
wanted to mention um this is just really
funny
newsmax the right wing media network
newsmax which has been railing against
vaccine protocols vaccine requirements
vaccine mandates for months at this
point has notified its own staff that it
will be implementing a vaccine mandate
um this is uh
the vaccine the um a vaccine mandate is
coming to newsmax rights media the
conservative news network informed
staffers of the move thursday in a
staff-wide email obtained by mediaite
newsmax cited the implementation of
covet rules by osha as its reason for
instituting the mandate the company
decree requires all employees to be
fully vaccinated by january 4th or they
will have to undergo a weekly coveted
test the email says to ensure that we
are in compliance we require all
vaccinated employees submit a copy of
their vaccination card the move is
unlikely to be well received by the
network's hosts a number of whom have
denounced vaccine mandates regularly
let's just look at just one or two
examples of that
um and i think there is just a brief ad
here we have to get by um yeah now i'm
gonna this is actually not that
hypocritical and i'll mention why in a
moment take a listen to this
he did he pushed america much closer to
full-on medical apartheid whoa a society
that is fundamentally divided into two
tears
biden used osha and other federal powers
and i really should say he abused those
powers to mandate that every single
worker in america get vaccinated by
early january and
all employees all employees in companies
with 100 or more workers must get
vaccinated or
face weekly testing but today now
i could go on and on with other examples
of this
the truth is that you could take a
position which is
you can be against it and the hosts can
be against it but if it's going to be
the law you're going to comply and
newsmax could very much take that
position now with the temporary freeze
on the vaccine mandate which we
mentioned earlier
maybe newsmax will go back on this i
don't know but what happened to
taking a stand what happened to i will
not comply what happened to we will
never do that thing which we are against
because it is their principle that is
violated all that different stuff
at the end of the day at minimum they
seem to be complying so this is not a
commentary on the legality of it newsmax
could be saying if it's the law we're
going to do it because we don't want to
be testing people daily uh this is not
necessarily a comment on the morality of
it because they could be saying well if
uh if it if if even if it's immoral
we're going to do it because it's too
difficult otherwise to manage the
testing and vaccination situation here
but
this is a testament to the fact that the
vaccine mandates work and that's one
thing that we've said time and again if
even newsmax which has been essentially
completely against this in terms of
their editorial position is saying but
we're still going to do it it is again
proof
that the vaccine requirements work and
that continues to be a very good sign
hey um i want to kind of go through a
sampling of the nutty stuff that
happened over this weekend with
republicans none of these clips that i'm
going to play for you
is sort of worthy of its own story but
sometimes it's just stunning how much
absurdity the american right gets into
over a 48-hour weekend that i want to
just give you like a little bit of a
tour through the bonkers um a
universe of the american right so let's
just look at a couple of things real
quick melania trump was given an award
by the log cabin republicans called the
spirit of lincoln award and melania gave
a speech with a teleprompter of course
even though trump and the right hates
teleprompters when obama uses them um
and it's just all very weird i amplified
legislation and created awareness
campaigns that elevated important issues
such as foster care
sickle cell disease
social emotional learning techniques
and neonatal absence
so just
everything is
so weird it's hard to even know
what the hell is going on with these
strange awards that they hand each other
so that was melania roger stone former
guest on this show
convicted pardoned okay you know roger
stone roger stone appeared on alex
jones's infowars
and said infowars is what you can trust
for the truth infowars is a beacon of
freedom that's why infowars can always
be counted on for the truth you can
always go to infowars.com and find out
what is really going on yeah now if
you're curious about roger stone check
out the time i interviewed him the big
kind of weird story with that was
up until about 30 seconds before the
interview you could hear him in the
background trying to get out of the
interview and then he sat down
and did the interview just an odd guy
and now this connection between i mean
this guy was a trump a really a trump in
as close to a friend as trump ever had
now just openly saying infowars is the
source that you have to trust um senator
josh hawley one of the insiders of the
january 6th insurrection did a very
strange sit-down interview with axios
and he went on a rant about the left
attacking manhood and he criticized
video games and porn just strange take a
look what's a man to you paint a picture
once a man well a man is a father a man
as a husband a man of somebody who takes
responsibility as conservatives we've
got to call men back to responsibility
we've got to say that spending your time
not working and we have more and more
men who are not working spending your
time on video games spending your time
watching porn online while doing nothing
is not good for you your family or this
country so viewers watching in this and
they're thinking really what the
liberals are doing are gonna push me to
watch pornhub more or play donkey kong
more do you mean that little really well
what i mean literally is that i think
the liberal attack the left-wing attack
on manhood says to men you're part of
the problem it says that your your
masculinity is inherently problematic
it's inherently oppressive what's your
what a weird interview and continued
right wing obsession
with these caricatures
of what i guess they see as the alpha
male
and the beta male
and
a very
unusual rant i guess i'm struggling to
even find the words for it for a sitting
senator to go on but video games and
porn that's
beta in the mind i guess of what josh
hawley sees as manhood
many anti-mask and anti-vaxx protests
continuing over the weekend not just in
the united states but in other countries
as we will soon see here's one from the
u.s here is a picture
of just one woman
holding a sign that says masks are child
abuse which they're not
masks are physical
and psychological abuse but
psychological is misspelled
on this woman's mask so that's something
in a completely
i i know i've i used this term last week
in another one of these kafka-esque
moments
here is cancun cruz republican senator
ted cruz
uh attacking john kerry for flying to
the climate conference last week on a
private jet and he points out
none of us have private jets and then
someone says actually uh ted rob portman
does have a private jet um take a look
at this
john kerry has a private jet
that has flown dozens of times this past
year all around the country
i don't know about you but i don't have
a private chat i don't believe any of
the people on this stage have their own
private jet portman
[Laughter]
one of the issues with making this
personal is you might have someone up on
the stage where the personal makes you
look like a hypocrite and of course the
bigger issue is how much should we be
talking about private jet use in
thinking about climate and as i talked
about last week
the people that have the private jets
are going to keep having the private
jets let's get them
off of fossil fuels and into renewables
that would be my preference and of
course the vast majority of carbon
emissions are not coming from aviation
at all never mind from private jets i
mentioned it last week and then here's
an australian anti-mask anti-vaxx guy
who's listing all of the things he
doesn't do
and hilariously he says he doesn't
satanize his hands instead of sanitize
it's satanized this is wild i'm 60 years
old i don't socially distance i never
wore a mask during the whole lockdown i
always go to the supermarket as much as
i like
i don't sterilize my hands or satanize
them i just live normally and naturally
just like i've always done of course
from time to time like anybody else i
might get ill and if i do i go to bed i
have some honey and lemon tea and i
sweat it out and then i recover this is
the way everyone should live
and i'm not against medicine but i think
medicine has taken too far we have too
much trust yes the satanization of hands
that's really something else so a wild
weekend in right wing la la land it's
more scary than funny you know
individually we might look at a clip and
we might say oh that actually is pretty
funny and we would be right to say it's
funny but the big picture is there is an
entire movement not just in the united
states but globally to some degree we've
seen it in europe we see it in australia
etc certainly here in the u.s an entire
movement based on not just ignorance but
pride in ignorance pride in non-thinking
pride in rejecting empiricism and
science and that's a really really bad
thing
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
we've been talking a lot about juries
including in the context of the kyle
rittenhouse trial i told my story of
serving on a jury last week and here is
a caller who says you know i think
lawyers want incompetent jurors they
don't want people who think for
themselves take a listen to this
hey david um it's it's alex um i was
just listening to your episode about um
jury and incompetence injuries and um
i'm actually a phd student and i have a
uh i haven't thought about that i feel
like um it may be more of a matter of
selection bias in some sense than it is
a matter of true incompetence i don't
know about your opinion but at least in
my experience it seems like most
um most lawyers try to select out the
most competent jurors intentionally and
so what you're left with is those that
are incompetent
rather than most people being
incompetent i don't know what your
thoughts are but that's mine so i i
still i continue to believe that a large
portion of people are just incompetent
at whatever they're doing you go to i
mean listen you go to most i don't know
retail stores or something like that a
lot of incompetence there you go to you
think in law everybody's competent i've
had some pretty bad experiences with it
with incompetent lawyers um i think that
there's two things going on i think
there are a lot of incompetent people in
general in the population but i do think
that
it may not be i spoke to a couple
lawyers about this who do jury trials
and they've said it's not that we want
incompetent people on the jury
but we want what they described as
simpler people now that that's
pejorative in a sense but what they mean
by it and they've explained it to me is
if you have a simpler jury
you can
more
easily predict how the jury will react
to certain
presentations either of evidence of
testimony etc and that's why in big jury
trials like you know murder trials etc
uh you may have a tendency not towards
incompetence per se
but towards folks who are more likely to
react in a predictable way rather than
quote thinking for themselves in ways
that may be unpredictable for both the
prosecutors and the defense that's what
lawyers have told me all right we've got
a great bonus show for you today we will
talk about the horrible surge in highway
deaths we're going to talk about sugar
has been blamed a lot for obesity but
sugar consumption is down and obesity
continues up what can we make of this
and we will talk about the horrible
tragedy at this travis scott concert
we're going to talk about crowd control
um and a lot of other things all on
today's bonus show
sign up at
joinpackman.com and you will get instant
access to today's bonus shot
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors disco delivers
affordable science-backed skin care
treatments to your home the disco
starter set helps guys fight oily skin
and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get 30 percent off at
letsdisco.com pacman the link is down
below